[Aplausos]
[Música]
michigan es famoso por sus grandes lagos
por ser el hogar de los cereales
kellogg's y del 'big air' y del
automóvil general motors ford y chrysler
hablamos del décimo estado más poblado
de los eeuu tiene casi 10 millones de
habitantes
[Música]
y estaríamos hablando del undécimo más
grande pero créeme en este caso el
tamaño no importa porque pues porque el
40% de michigan es agua a ver si os
creíais que eso de los grandes lagos era
un farol tienen agua para poder sumergir
toda la república checa- y parte de
eslovaquia pero hoy no vamos a hablaros
de las maravillas naturales de michigan
hoy toca hablar de las elecciones
presidenciales del año 2020 el martes 3
de noviembre se acerca a toda velocidad
y lo cierto es que las presidenciales se
han puesto de repente muy pero que muy
interesantes hace tan sólo un año
parecía evidente la reelección de trump
pero 2020 y el coronavirus lo han
cambiado absolutamente
defensor político creemos que para
entender bien las elecciones de eeuu no
podemos verlas como las de un país
cohesionado sino tiene que haberlas
estado por estado hay muchos estados que
tradicionalmente votan al mismo partido
por ejemplo california lleva 32 años
apostando por el candidato demócrata y
texas 44 años por el republicano y todo
indica que mantendrán su fidelidad por
cuatro años más sin embargo también
tenemos los llamados swing states
estados en los que la victoria está
mucho más disputada pues bien uno de los
estados es michigan
ahí está a detroit que es la capital del
automóvil hablamos por tanto de un
estado con mucha industria muchas
fábricas y por tanto muchos votantes que
pertenecen a la clase trabajadora a la
clase obrera
en principio podríamos pensar que estos
votantes son mucho más propensos a votar
a los demócratas es decir a votar al
partido de izquierdas verdad pues lo
cierto es que no en el año 2016 donald
trump se metió en el bolsillo a todos
estos votantes gracias a su discurso
contra china se hizo así con buena parte
de aquellos que habían votado por bernie
sanders en las primarias demócratas que
estamos hablando de los situados más a
la izquierda del partido es decir los
más próximos a los movimientos
sindicales trabajadores que se sintieron
traicionados por los que cortan el
bacalao en washington gente que
considera que el partido demócrata se
preocupa más por defender a las minorías
que a la clase trabajadora de toda la
vida y eso trump los hubo aprovechar
mejor que nadie más concretamente su por
entonces jefe de campaña que era nada
más y nada menos que el señor steve para
no
state bank on hemos convertido a los
republicanos en el partido de la clase
trabajadora así que contra todo
pronóstico michigan voto por donald
trump en 2016 tras seis elecciones
presidenciales apoyando los candidatos
demócratas ese año apostaron por un
republicano un cambio que al final fue
decisivo para conseguir que trump
llegara a la casa blanca pues bien ahora
trump opta a la reelección y se
presentará ante las urnas en su peor
momento el país afrontó un panorama
económico desolador mientras continúa la
lucha contra el coronavirus y ya sé lo
que me vais a decir ver la pandemia es
algo global y las dificultades
económicas se afectan a todo el mundo
pero al votante estadounidense lo que le
preocupa es lo suyo así que la pregunta
que nos hacemos es por qué en michigan
es tan importante que nos hace pensar
que los mexiquenses podrían votar por
bailén o que tal vez podrían quedarse
otra vez con donald trump decidir a
michigan en noviembre quien ocupa la
casa blanca durante los próximos cuatro
años hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
el colegio electoral si pensáis que eeuu
es una democracia y que por tanto todo
se resume en ver quién consigue más
votos siento decíroslo prestáis muy
equivocados hace cuatro años vimos muy
bien porque ya son cinco las veces en la
historia de eeuu en las que el candidato
que obtuvo más votos populares no fue
quien llegó a ser el ocupante de la casa
blanca cinco veces en las que salió
beneficiado el candidato del partido
republicano las dos últimas son muy
recientes una fue hace 20 años cuando
bush se impuso por muy poquito sobre
algo y la siguiente fue en 2016 cuando
trump superó a hillary clinton
tenéis que recordar que hillary clinton
tuvo casi 3 millones de votos más que
donald trump dos puntos porcentuales
sin embargo trump estuvo sobradísimo a
la hora de la verdad tuvo 304 votos del
colegio electoral frente a los 227 de
hillary clinton
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero esto por qué pasa
porque eeuu tiene un sistema tan
aparentemente antidemocrático pues por
raro que suene tiene mucha lógica veréis
eeuu es un estado federal compuesto por
50 estados cada uno con su propia
idiosincrasia ahora imagina por un
momento que surgiera un candidato odiado
en todo el país pero muy popular en
california o en texas que son los dos
estados más poblados del país
ahora imagina que este candidato
consiguiera que casi todos los
californianos o casi todos los tejanos
le apoyaran tanto en porcentaje de voto
como en porcentaje de participación de
repente los californianos o los tejanos
podrían imponer sus condiciones sobre el
resto de estados y por eso eeuu tiene un
sistema electoral ideado para cumplir
una misión evitar la victoria de un
candidato apoyado solamente en una
región del país aunque ese apoyo sea muy
muy muy fuerte de hecho casi todas las
democracias tienen un sistema bastante
parecido en casi todos los países el
primer ministro no es elegido por
votación directa sino que los ciudadanos
votan a un parlamento y a su vez este
parlamento vota al primer ministro y por
eso las elecciones hay que verlas estado
por estado tanto en eeuu como en
cualquier otro país en eeuu los votantes
eligen a los 538 miembros del colegio
electoral la única misión de este
colegio electoral es elegir al
presidente y al vicepresidente la
constitución de eeuu dice que las
elecciones federales se celebran el
martes después del primer lunes de
noviembre y que él
y electoral de cada estado tiene que
emitir sus votos el primer lunes
siguiente al segundo miércoles de
diciembre
[Música]
estos 538 lectores ni siquiera se llegan
a reunir conjuntamente no no no el día
señalado de diciembre acuden a las
capitales de sus respectivos estados y
desde allí emiten sus votos y os
preguntaréis y porque son 538 son un
montón si al final simplemente actúan
como meros compromisarios pues son 538
porque es la suma de los 435 miembros de
la cámara de representantes que se
distribuyen según la población de cada
estado más los 100 miembros del senado
que son dos por estado
independientemente de su población
también habría que sumar otros tres que
representan al distrito de columbia es
decir a washington que es la capital
federal que no pertenece a ningún estado
así que ya habéis visto que la
distribución de miembros del colegio
electoral va más o menos en función de
la población de cada estado y por eso
california tiene 55 votos en el colegio
electoral texas 38 y a michigan le
corresponden 16 electores
pero esperad un momento porque aquí es
cuando llega lo realmente interesante en
la mayor parte de los estados el
candidato ganador se lleva todos los
electores por ejemplo supongamos que joe
biden gana las elecciones en california
cosa bastante probable dada la
idiosincrasia de este estado pues bien
cuando esos 55 representantes del
colegio electoral se reúnan en diciembre
todos votarán a piden por eso no importa
que un candidato gane las elecciones en
michigan por un voto o por un millón de
votos lo importante es ganar el
candidato conseguiría así los 16 votos
del colegio electoral y estaría más
cerca de los 270 que son necesarios para
ser presidente tan solo nebraska y maine
reparte sus lectores de forma
proporcional a los votos
y por eso michigan es tan importante
porque aunque 16 votos os pueda parecer
pocos tened en cuenta que es uno de esos
swing states que más votos pone en juego
y no perdáis de vista una obviedad pero
que es muy interesante al estar hablando
de un sistema bipartidista y es que
hablamos de 16 electores que gana un
candidato y 16 electores que deja de
ganar el otro candidato hace cuatro años
77 votos del colegio electoral fueron lo
que separaron a trump de hillary clinton
con estos cálculos michigan representa
32 votos que ya no nos parecen tan pocos
la cuestión ahora es y los votantes de
michigan como ve en estas elecciones que
piensan por allí pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
el juguete roto del capitalismo
americano michigan carece de grandes
ciudades aparte de detroit aún así la
mayor parte de su población se concentra
en núcleos urbanos sólo un 18% vive en
el medio rural y la industria fue un
papel esencial en la economía de
michigan aporta un 30% del pib del
estado la gran recesión de 2009 fue un
momento crítico para todo eeuu en
anteriores vídeos de visual política ya
os hemos contado los problemas por los
que ha atravesado detroit y ya os hemos
hablado de como esta ciudad se consiguió
reinventar y volver a generar empleo en
el cinturón de óxido a la alta
tecnología como repuntó el empleo en
michigan
aún así como podéis imaginar casi todo
sigue girando en torno a la industria
del automóvil a día de hoy el estado de
michigan produce más de 2 millones de
coches al año esto es más o menos los
mismos que toda francia así que si hay
un montón de trabajadores que dependen
del sector automovilístico gente que en
su día quiso un candidato como bernie
sanders y que se encontró con hillary
clinton así que votaron por donald trump
presidenciales hartos de un sistema
económico que durante décadas había
favorecido las deslocalizaciones un
sistema económico que había permitido
que las fábricas se hubieran marchado a
otros países
recordad que detroit alcanzó su mejor
momento en los años 50 del siglo pasado
y que desde entonces no ha parado de
perder población entró en un bucle de
cierre de fábricas precariedad y aumento
de la criminalidad que nadie supo
realmente cómo trabajar así que la
crisis del año 2009 supuso la puntilla
para muchos trabajadores la ciudad de
detroit acabó en la bancarrota eran
tiempos difíciles donde día tras día se
veían noticias tan dantescas como estas
las casas de detroit se venden por un
dólar en medio de la crisis de la
industria automotriz y las hipotecas en
este caso el gobierno federal se vio
obligado a intervenir es decir hacer
algo para solucionar el problema y en
aquellos años era el gobierno de barack
obama bueno en realidad barack obama era
el presidente porque el vicepresidente
era joe biden y si hablamos del mismo
que ahora se presenta como contrincante
de donald trump todo este dinero público
sirvió para rescatar a general motors ya
chrysler que estaban en bancarrota
fort también tuvo que pedir un crédito
para evitar la quiebra y este rescate
supuso una inyección de 80.000 millones
de dólares de los que aproximadamente 10
mil millones nunca se recuperaron
ahora bien este rescate logró recuperar
un sector clave para la economía de
michigan y salvar un montón de puestos
de trabajo este rescate fue tan
importante que se convirtió en el gran
protagonista de la superbowl de 2012 por
si no lo sabéis la super bowl es el
partido más importante del fútbol
americano y los anuncios que se emiten
en el descanso son los más caros de todo
el año pues bien en 2012 chrysler
contrató el mismísimo clint eastwood
para que protagonizará este anuncio
el agente de detroit hará algo sobre
esto casi lo pierden todos
[Música]
todos nos unimos y ahora motorcity está
luchando de nuevo por supuesto detroit
sigue siendo una sombra de lo que era en
1950 y los trabajadores aún temen perder
sus empleos y por eso los discursos del
américa first y los ataques contra china
y las fábricas que se deslocaliza van a
mexico sonaban como música celestial
esos trabajadores que tenían miedo de
perder su trabajo se echaron en brazos
del único que parecía dispuesto a evitar
las terribles deslocalizaciones
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando todos
los políticos hacen promesas en campaña
electoral promesas que seamos honestos
nunca cumplen pero hay que reconocer que
al menos en este aspecto
donald trump no ha engañado a nadie
trump prometió mano dura contra china y
contra méxico y el america first se
tradujo en medidas muy concretas por un
lado la renegociación del tratado de
libre comercio de américa del norte y
por supuesto en la que todos conocemos
la guerra comercial contra china parecía
que por fin alguien se preocupaba por la
clase obrera de eeuu y alguien había
escuchado a esos trabajadores por fin
les daban lo que querían
pero ya sabéis el dicho en cuidado con
lo que deseas porque puede hacerse
realidad tratar de frenar el comercio
contra china no ha traído los trabajos
de vuelta a eeuu más bien todo lo
contrario atentos
los empresarios de michigan aseguran que
los aranceles de trampa han arruinado
sus negocios en los tiempos anteriores
al coronavirus solía decirse que trump
será muchas cosas pero la economía va
mejor que nunca o que la bolsa con
trampa está subiendo como la espuma y sí
es cierto que ha subido ha subido para
las empresas tecnológicas es decir si
trabajas en amazon google o microsoft tu
puesto de trabajo está más que asegurado
pero a la gente que trabaja en michigan
la bolsa les importa más bien poco allí
lo que les importa es lo que sucede con
la industria del automóvil y esta ha
sido una de las grandes perdedoras de la
guerra comercial para que os hagáis una
idea antes de coronavirus las fábricas
de coches de michigan ya habían perdido
dos mil cien empleos es decir tenían
2100 empleos menos que cuando donald
trump llegó al poder y todo esto era
antes de coronavirus y diréis y qué ha
pasado después pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
el coronavirus sobre ruedas cuando llegó
la crisis sanitaria provocada por el
coronavirus trump no quería tomar
medidas pero la gobernadora de michigan
si la demócrata gretchen witmer ordenó
el tercer confinamiento más largo de
todo eeuu y aún así el estado de
michigan ha acumulado más de 7.000
muertos por el cob y 19 las
restricciones más duras fueron impuestas
cuando el coronavirus ya estaba
desbocado abril fue terrible michigan
con 150 muertos cada día y os
preguntaréis se evitaron más muertes con
el confinamiento pues seguramente si aún
así hubo fuertes protestas contra la
cuarentena y os preguntaréis había
alguna alternativa pues algunos creen
que también liberad michigan los
ciudadanos de michigan estuvieron 70
días recluidos en sus casas desde
finales de marzo hasta principios de
junio y esto ha afectado sobre todo a
los trabajadores de la industria de tron
se ubica en el condado de wayne que
concentra al 18% de la población del
estado de michigan sin embargo el
condado de wayne acumula el 25 por
ciento de los positivos en michigan por
kobe 19 y el 40% de los
pero no creáis que hablamos sólo de
vidas también hablamos de economía
[Música]
la tasa de desempleo de michigan superó
22 por ciento peor que la gran recesión
actualmente el desempleo se ha
recuperado hasta el 8% pero sigue siendo
el doble del 4% en el que estaba antes
de la pandemia y si no se recupera más
es en gran medida por las políticas de
trump por ejemplo la agricultura y la
industria siguen siendo lastradas por
los efectos de la guerra comercial los
productos agrícolas están siendo
perjudicados por los aranceles y la
industria ha visto cómo se reducen sus
exportaciones al tiempo que los
materiales que utilizan se encarecen y
de nuevo lo pagan los agricultores que
tienen que soportar precios más elevados
al comprar maquinaria como os podéis
imaginar todo esto genera un montón de
malestar en los trabajadores un malestar
que no para de crecer al ver que la
guerra comercial sólo les ha generado
problemas
y entonces los ciudadanos de michigan es
cuando se preguntan y cuál es la
alternativa a donald trump y aquí es
cuando entra en escena yo
[Música]
la primera ventaja de joe biden es que
no es hillary clinton de hecho la peor
noticia para trump es que bailen no es
hillary clinton clinton generaba
muchísimo rechazo pero yo baiden no
tanto pero por encima de todo la gran
baza de bailén es la situación las
elecciones de 2016 se plantearon en
términos de que queréis seguir igual con
la clase política de toda la vida que
representa a hillary clinton o probar
algo nuevo con donald trump el
empresario famoso que sale por la tele
en michigan ganaron por la mínima los
que apostaron por la novedad y se puede
decir que cuatro años después no les
termina de convencer además la pandemia
ha provocado una situación crítica en la
que los demócratas están explotando la
experiencia de bailén como
vicepresidente durante la gran recesión
[Música]
especialmente el hecho de que fuera
payden quien impulsará ese plan de
rescate que salvó a la industria de la
automoción de michigan un plan que por
cierto recibió el voto en contra de mike
pence que por si no lo sabéis es el
vicepresidente de donald trampa
así de michigan es uno de los campos de
batalla más importantes tanto para trump
como para baile hace cuatro años trump
llegó a la casa blanca gracias a una
victoria sorpresa en michigan
pensilvania y wisconsin pero en michigan
lo hizo por apenas 10 mil 700 otros y en
los otros dos estados también fue por la
mínima en total la victoria de trump en
estos tres estados fue atentos por 67
mil votos hablamos por tanto de 46
electores que de haber caído del bando
demócrata hubieran cambiado por completo
el resultado de las elecciones por eso
unos pocos miles de votos en michigan
pueden ser cruciales para la victoria de
trump o la victoria de bailén así que la
pregunta es cómo va la campaña pues
atentos
la política en los tiempos del cob y
pocas veces podremos ver tus formas tan
radicalmente distintas de afrontar tanto
una campaña electoral como una pandemia
como la vida misma en michigan las
encuestas dan de momento una ventaja
clarísima a bailén una ventaja de
alrededor de 7 puntos así que donald
trump ha pasado al ataque como si fuera
el mismísimo general caster los
partidarios del actual presidente han
sacado al 7º de caballería para atacar a
bailén y le han llamado de todo pero
absolutamente de todo le han llamado
hasta pedófilo y os preguntaréis y cómo
está respondiendo baile pues haciendo
prácticamente nada
[Música]
tal cual como lo oís la estrategia de
bailén tiene un perfil muy pero que muy
bajo podríamos decir que es una de las
campañas menos agresivas de la historia
de la democracia estadounidense podéis
esperar que piden quisiera dar una
imagen de gran renovador o del líder
carismático pero está haciendo justo lo
contrario
su mensaje es queréis volver a los
políticos de toda la vida queréis volver
a esos políticos aburridos pues aquí me
tenéis para que os hagáis una idea la
campaña de vaivén es tan anodina que
incluso sus defensores se están poniendo
nerviosos atentos
michael moore alarma sobre la campaña de
buy de michigan en realidad está siendo
peor que la de hillary vaivén ha
prometido para michigan un millón de
empleos en la automoción con su vida
back éter 80 y poco más su campaña no
está apostando todo por lo digital con
el pretexto de guardar la distancia de
seguridad con los votantes algo que le
viene bastante bien porque seamos
honestos el señor joe vaivén no es
precisamente la alegría de la güerta así
que la campaña de bailén está
invirtiendo un montón de dinero en
anuncios de televisión y redes sociales
justo lo contrario que donald trump la
campaña del presidente canceló en julio
sus anuncios televisivos en michigan
muchos interpretaron entonces quedaba la
guerra por pérdida en este estado al ver
la macro ventaja de bailén en las
encuestas
pero esperad un momento porque los
republicanos podrían estar repitiendo la
estrategia de 2016 en esas elecciones
reservaron para el último momento el
bombardeo de anuncios se volcaron en
octubre en los estados clave para
conseguir dar un vuelco en las encuestas
y lo cierto a la vista está que la
estrategia le salió a las mil maravillas
sin embargo esta vez es distinta os
preguntaréis tiene trump alguna
propuesta estrella para michigan pues lo
cierto es que no mantienen la misma
narrativa que en el año 2016 voy a
evitar que china o robe los trabajos en
realidad podríamos decir que la campaña
republicana se parece demasiado a la de
2016 parece que la pandemia no les ha
afectado en absoluto sus partidarios van
puerta por puerta intentando convencer
de las virtudes del presidente olvidando
las distancias de seguridad y en cuanto
pueden celebran actos multitudinarios
cierto es que lo hicieron en el hangar
de un aeropuerto al aire libre pero
juntar más de cinco mil personas no
parece una buena idea en los tiempos que
corren bueno a él sí que le parece una
buena idea
una persona que va en segundo lugar no
congrega a esta multitud
vosotros lo sabéis pasó lo mismo hace
cuatro años como veis las espadas siguen
en todo lo alto en michigan así que como
no seguiremos atentos a lo que sucede en
noviembre pero ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que los votantes
deberían juzgar la presidencia de donald
trump dejando al margen la pandemia
pensáis que los resultados de michigan
volverán a estar tan ajustados es más si
fuerais me siguen 6 seguiréis con trump
o apostar y aix por bailén podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones recordar también que
hemos sacado un nuevo canal que se llama
mega proyectos con cada visual polític
que recomiendo muchísimo que visitéis si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]